what's tsb your favorite covergirl
checking in live and check me out on the
bootleg kev show
yo sabula cav show special guest in here
you know her her name is bia
wow that was a great intro you know her
she's here let me see
i've been paying attention to your
journey for a very long time
and congratulations because this i know
that this success uh
is is is uh well deserved you've been
grinding for a very long time i've been
seeing other chicks
pop off and you know you you've been
here the whole time and like
to finally see you kind of break through
is delta c thank you so much it's been
like like you said
a long ass journey yeah i wouldn't
change it man like if i could go back
like i wouldn't have done
anything different like yeah because i
feel like you were shout out to you
too because i remember was it you were
rca yeah
and then uh you i mean they didn't do
[ __ ] with you they didn't know what to
do with you
uh and then the russ record popped and i
think right when the
record popped you became like a free
agent i was actually a free agent a week
before the rest right like it all lined
up
it's like it's like the stars of
lionfish it was god bro like
it's for real like i couldn't have wrote
that no other way
yeah because i remember um you know i'm
cool cool with the uh you know your old
a
r uh rca shout out leaving my name very
that's my boy
i'm saying but um yeah i remember always
thinking like man this girl b is so fire
like
like and then i would see other chicks
who aren't as fire as you like
you know catch some [ __ ] and i'm like
man and then that russ record happened
and i remember someone telling him i
think russ
told me russ was like yo yeah she's a
free agent now
and i was like oh [ __ ] and then when i
found out you were epic i'm out you're
in good hands
now yeah i love it over there like we
love epic
yeah and now now you got this this whole
lot of money song that's going insane
crazy yeah so for people who don't know
how long have you been rapping
so i've been rapping probably for like i
want to say
10 years but like really
like really really rapping for probably
like seven years like
yeah about that and so for uh like i'm
you originally did pharrell kind of
discover you like kind of give us a
background on you and pharrell like
like back back when you kind of cause i
think that's how maybe some people might
have first heard of you so actually
family discovered me
shout out to family yeah virginia
he's the original because like you know
nobody believed in me
until he did and then you know it was
just just him believing in me for a long
time and then
you know then pharrell and
and it was just it's really hard when
you have to put all that pressure on
on just only two people like you know
what i'm saying to try to get the world
to see what you see
that early on is like it's very hard to
do and you know i respect and love them
forever for doing that for me because
when you stamp something that early it's
like that's genuine
that's big yeah i mean and then also
like you know pharrell
outside of kalis like i don't i can't i
mean felicia is obviously a singer but
like i i mean
to have someone like that cosign you as
a female mc and by the way
at the time you know there's been this
big female emcee renaissance which has
been amazing to see
but at the time i feel like it was just
so it was kind of a weird time to be a
female rapper right because it was
really just nikki
and then it was like i mean
everybody i mean it was like you know
there was like people like nitti scott
mc and rhapsody and all these dope like
people making noise on the underground
but it was really like
i i i'm so happy that the the ceiling
has gotten broken through of there only
being one
it female rapper at a time because that
shit's over with now yeah
i mean i think it's been over with but
just now you have the
industry accepting it because it's a
different thing when
there's always been girls rapping of
course there's always been girls that
were fired you know
and they just didn't get their due
because
you know the way it was set up so it's
like now that i think like as one girl
starts to go then another girl goes and
another girl goes
it's making people open their eyes and
making labels wake up and be like hey
listen
wheat festivals everything we have to
start pouring into the girls a little
bit more because
there's something going on here the
people are picking it like
you know what i'm saying the people are
the ones that consumers are are speaking
through yeah 100 um when you first kind
of started to see this record uh
this whole lot of money record go crazy
on tick tock like what was like
like like what was the moment where you
realize oh this shit's this is
kind of a thing was it like a certain
person who who did something to it like
because
it seemed like it popped pretty quick i
we were in puerto rico shooting a video
and um you know just on like a little
recording vacation and then
when we came back is when it was it was
going viral like
the day we came back and we loved a
whole lot of money like my whole team
like everybody on my side we
we always felt like that record was
special but we just
like we we're in the business of just
letting the people pick what they love
and you know moving on to the next
record like we don't get married to
anything or
think like oh if this doesn't work out
it's over you know we're always in the
in the game to just keep it keep it keep
the momentum rolling so
um we didn't expect it but after it
happened we were so happy about it
because it was one that you guys already
loved yeah it was the one that we were
like oh we added this song last
like you know we we didn't really fight
for it because it wasn't a fight but we
we were all like do we should we think
we should have this yeah yeah we have to
like do you feel like back in like when
you first kind of started like
was that an uphill battle to be like man
i
like you gotta kind of get a single to
pop you know what i'm saying
that was the worst right like it's like
you're almost like and your man's he's
the king of that like oh yeah
he's the king of like certain people uh
my old a
r he was like the king of like you need
a hit single
hey by the way that same similar things
happen with other people
and that and that works for some people
no no but i'm saying like that also
stalled out a lot of dope artists on
that same label that's what i'm trying
to say that that either
that's like the that's cancer to an
artist like when you
don't allow them to be productive and
consistent you kill their momentum so
it's like
you kill everything that they have going
on so for some artists that works
they could come out the gate with one
hit then wait till they get the next one
and come out the gate with another hit
yeah but that's not how you build fans
that's not how you build
yeah an identity exactly because if
you're known as like the radio artist
then what happens when you don't have a
radio record and that's just not the
artist i want it to be
right i have more depth i feel i felt
like there was a lot of music that i had
that wasn't going to see the light of
day that needed to see the light of day
and um were you able to take any of your
stuff that you recorded over there with
you
i didn't i didn't but that's okay
because
my my boys would tell you like i record
bro like
right i could cut records like i'll go
in there i could have a day where i
might leave with three i could have a
day where i might leave with six
you know what i'm saying and everybody
that's ever been in the studio with me
knows that and they know it's
it's it's more where that came from i
feel like you know sometimes like that
that'll happen where an artist will be
like damn like i'm really
married to these songs but if you're
really like if you're really that
[ __ ] like
it's all good you just make new ones
mm-hmm you know i mean and
and also what that mentality we're
talking about is it almost like
i hate to see when when really dope
[ __ ] like get put in situations
where
the label really make them uh question
themselves to second guess how dope they
are because
the single ain't hit or you know what
i'm saying it's like man like
you're fire like i've been been thinking
your fire for a long time and
did you ever have that situation where
you kind of started to question yourself
like
because i know you know
the old conventional way of this [ __ ]
was hey we need it we need a single to
pop you off
that that was my whole i felt like that
was the whole beginning of my career
where i felt like i was constantly
questioning myself
and my own abilities because it wasn't
working and i'm like what am i doing
wrong what am i doing wrong
i'm constantly going back to the to the
drawing board and trying to reinvent or
come up with something else or mimic
what they're telling me i should be like
you know what i'm saying
and i got to a place where i was like
i don't know what what happened really
but i got charged up like you know when
you just
you stopped taking [ __ ] and you just
like yeah you know what you got i got so
angry that it it forced me to no longer
seek no validation
and just pour that into myself like yeah
like it's almost like you're here for a
reason
it's because you're dope like just yeah
just
be do you took the fun out of it yeah
cause then it feels like a job because
then you're not creating for the love or
for yourself you're creating for what
you think people want to hear
exactly and then when i got back to the
basics like
when i got out of the label situation
and i had nobody just my friends
we were going to the studio every day um
you know just recording as friends
and i'm like you know this is fun this
is hot this is why we did it in the
first place
this is what this used to feel like so
now i just chase that like as long as
i'm having a good time and i'm i'm
around good people good energy and i
protect that vibe i don't work with
everybody because you can't get that way
everywhere
who's who who are artists that you enjoy
working with where you get that vibe
like like or or producers just someone
who you've gotten in with real life this
is
this is great um i love my homeboys
little rich and disease
they are like two of my best friends and
they are hilarious like he's hilarious
he has me cracking up the whole time um
london j is really fire
uh t romano like any other art
what about any other artists that you've
gotten where it just felt organic
and russ russ is he's a genius
yeah i saw the video of you guys working
on best on earth together that just
fell j balvin baldwin jay baldwin is a
vibe like he's
he's so talented and you know like
honestly pharrell
is a vibe to be in the studio with like
to soak up
if like anyone that's ever been in
studio with pharrell to soak up from him
and to see his process
like he'll you'll learn some [ __ ] like
so
yeah pharrell i think is uh you know
there's a few guys that i think every
artist has like on their checklist to
work with it's like dr
dre pharrell yeah
he's like that like i would just watch
him like wow like
did you learn a lot that you replied to
your own creative process from being
around him so much
absolutely like if something don't feel
right i get off of it like you know
like i don't sit there and try to write
a line for like
10 hours like if it doesn't feel right
it's like move on let's move on like
let's move on and come back to it
because
it should be natural it should feel good
it shouldn't feel like homework
hey and then the you know i think that
that moment with best on earth was big
because
again you had just got out of your deal
that that record
went crazy obviously russ he he puts out
i think
you know a lot of artists should follow
his blueprint as in terms
in terms of just how he releases music
and builds his fans but like
it was one of the records that he you
know he puts out a lot of songs
that record comes out i think was
rihanna posted it
right and it was just off to the races
like what was that first of all
at the time russ i think russ is another
person who everything he does is very
organic as far as the people he works
with like i never see russ force any
features like he's like yo if i [ __ ]
with him i [ __ ] with him
like he's a he was he was a fan of you
to work with yes
like i was offended him too so like i
love his music so
when he hit me he was in l.a he's like
i'm in la like
you know i got some studio sessions and
he don't even do studio sessions like
out at the studio he recorded at home at
home yeah so he's like you know i'm out
here i don't really do this [ __ ] but i
got a session if you got time i'd like
for you to pull up i got some beats for
you
so he had some beats originally and to
play me
as i was listening to them we heard the
the best on earth
and we were like man let's get on this
right now we just both felt it cut
it right away he did a hook i did the
other half he did a verse i did the
other half for the rest so
it was organic like thrilled that's fire
that's fire we were talking earlier
about shrooms you said you've had some
bad shroom experiences
tell me about the uh craziest shroom
experience you
you've had you just put me on the spot
listen we've all i mean i don't know
about we've all had bags i don't know
because i don't want people to think i'm
weird you know what i'm saying like what
because you did shrooms
no because like my experience oh yeah
tell me what happened please like i
don't want them to be like
yo she was tripping so i saw a ufo
like if i i was in brickell you know i
was looking out
looking at my hotel i saw a ufo
that's in miami right in miami yeah i
saw a ufo it was like four in the
morning
i'm laying with my boyfriend and we're
both looking at it
but we felt asleep but we were awake
it was weird it's like my mind was was
awake
but my eyes was closed but i was fully
awake i wasn't
asleep but then i opened my eyes so
let me not say my eyes was closed this
is not making sense anywho i was laying
down
i was looking out the window and i saw a
ufo i didn't want to say anything like
yo you see that ufo because
i didn't want to think i was crazy did
he see the ufo as well let me tell you
so the next day
i saw the uf i asked him like i told
somebody in front of him i'm like oh
you know i thought i saw a ufo yesterday
he said i seen it too but i didn't want
to say anything because i thought i was
tripping
and i i wanted to see if you would bring
it up today and i was like yes
i saw it like i knew it was a ufo it was
doing this little weird [ __ ] and then it
just
shot and disintegrated like shot down
and disintegrated and what the [ __ ]
flies down
everything flies up you know what i'm
saying it was like yo what's crazy is
they just put a video out uh this this
do you see that video that just came out
that they confirmed is real
uh it's like a naval ship and they have
like their radar thing
and um they they the government said it
it's like a real video
i know because i've been meeting people
that have seen it it was in the snow not
that but ufos no it was a ufo in the sky
over the water and then it dived down
into the water and disappeared
that's what i saw that's what i saw
yeah i'm not kidding bro like and obama
just came out
two days ago and said that the [ __ ] is
real there's ufos so i don't know
exactly what it was but i know that that
wasn't something that
was normal i've never seen it again i
was only i only seen it on shrooms
so ever since i've been wanting to like
you know
i've just been wanting to see some [ __ ]
like that again but i feel like you can
only crack those levels
maybe on like the right amount of
shrooms you know yeah i think that uh
i mean listen i mean there's no proven
science but i think if you
something gets unlocked in your brain
maybe you could see things a little bit
different you know your third eye gets a
little
i don't know man i mean you know how
[ __ ] starts melting sometimes when
you're on shrubs
oh i know like one time my whole fridge
was melting like i looked to the left
sliding down i'm like what is going on
yeah the last time i did shrooms i was
in texas
and me and freddie gibbs were at a bar
[ __ ] up and there was some chick
dancing by herself and her face was
censored like she was on cops
what her face was all scrambled and she
like she's like you know like there was
a sensor like her face was censored
and i was like bro i was like bro you
see this [ __ ] like
am i tripping or is her face [ __ ]
like she looks like she's on an episode
of cops and did he see it
uh i don't think he's i was really
[ __ ] up he wasn't as [ __ ] i was [ __ ]
that was a rough night for me that was
one of the worst nights of my life as
far as just freaking the [ __ ] out
but yeah that was yeah i think you know
it's interesting because you do hear
that a lot when people do it together
they usually see the same [ __ ] we just
had who
whiz was telling us that about his mom
he said him and his mom
uh they did shrooms together at
coachella and they saw all the same [ __ ]
i would love to do shrooms with my mom
that's lit hey what up man
how to interrupt the bootleg cab podcast
to tell you about our good friends
at odd socks all right yo shout out to
them for
sponsoring the podcast but also for
being such a fire company
and they just introduced their draws
that's right odd socks now got your
boxer briefs on deck
some tapatio joints and then of course
they got the best socks in the game
look at these stone cold socks look at
these two i mean look
i love froot loops but i love these
froot loops socks these are fire i'm
taking those for myself
uh they got all the licenses breaking
bad mac dre
odb wwe street fighter whatever you want
they got
including these draws i love these
drawers i got some on right now
so listen tap in with odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev and you will
save 20
off at checkout so oddsoxofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev
save 20 to check out and thank me later
would your mom do shrooms with you
probably not she's like kind of she's
like oh no i
i can't do that like she's like one of
those what's your ethnicity
she's italian my mom's italian okay what
about your dad my dad
is puerto rican and a little bit of
black and white well okay
a little bit black and native american
but
she's like a mix but you came up in
boston
mm-hmm which is um a dope city
uh it's an interesting city i've been
there a lot so i know a lot about boston
i mean i i love it i love little italy
there especially food i've ever had by
the way shout out to boston
but it's also like kind of perceived as
like a racist city kind of it is
is it a racist city it was perceived
that way it's perceived that way yeah
it's like that in some places though
because you know it's it's kind of like
we just think of like drunk
white irish dudes out there they have
those you know you watch the departed
and [ __ ] and you're like
is everyone like where there's townies
and they does everyone sound like bill
burr when they talk
no no they they do they sound
you know what i hate about people they
don't think that boston has like any
culture that massachusetts has like
any blacks or latinos like there's a lot
of culture out there
of course it's just in its own areas
like yeah i mean look i mean which i'm
earlier i love
i love lawrence lawrence is a dope area
yeah lawrence is all
puerto ricans and dominicans hey
terminology's from boston and he's
puerto rican
yeah i [ __ ] with him shout out to term
one of the most underrated dudes
he's a legend a legend for sure
and then there's like ben let's give him
his flowers while he's right here let me
tell you something about terminology
static selected 1982. you know what i
mean shout out to my guys
good dad gang go buy a [ __ ]
terminology everybody from boston
they're flowers right now
let's give the celtics their flowers are
we going to give the bruins are we going
to get benjamin
and cam newton his flowers yes because
it's koi's dad and that's my girl
everybody from boston gets their flowers
yeah coyla rae
shout out to coyla ray man she's doing
her thing yeah that's my girl i [ __ ]
with her
yeah she's i love her energy me too very
positive she's just having fun
you know what i'm saying i love it yeah
boston is yeah but you know
there's there's so many uh legendary
cool people from boston hell yeah
static selected one of the greatest
hip-hop producers of all time and my
brother man i love that guy man so
it's it's crazy because it's such a boom
bap hip hop city like
i feel like you come out of boston like
you got to have a real respect for like
the art form mm-hmm you know what i'm
saying like and i don't feel like a lot
of
artists who are your peers have that
luxury of coming from that background
you know what i'm saying
because it's a different generation you
know gen z is a little different
yeah they don't really respect like the
new generation is like
i don't [ __ ] about them old heads like
well i'm already known and their biggest
influences are chief keith and soulja
boy
and i like chief keefe and so yeah of
course but i also
i respect muse like i grew up on like
gnaws and like you know
real rap so what's your um
okay how about this besides illmatic
what's your favorite nas album
stillmatic still manicure i respect it
i respect it the lost tapes too oh lost
i could definitely run back the lost
tapes and they pop away first no the
first last tapes okay i i didn't i was
hoping you didn't say lost tapes too
because part two of lost tapes that came
out a couple years ago was disney no i'm
talking about the first lost tapes
tapes the original last names like that
purple
yeah like i love [ __ ] like laser 50
blazer 50 is one of the best
storytelling songs ever that's the one
thing when i when i never i talk to nas
next i want to ask raps like that
anymore i want to ask knowledge who
what what girl was blazer50 about did
she [ __ ] someone
on the broncos during their super bowl
run and she [ __ ] you
so who was it i think he said he was she
used to [ __ ] terrell davis from the
broncos on that song shout out to nas
man
i have to run that one back who's your
favorite uh if you had to give me your
top five
all time who is it top five i hate that
question
favorite not greatest of all time
because you know there's two two
different questions i i got
artists that are my favorite like yeah
that says
like every time i put pusha t i put
pusha t so high on my favorites
of all time and people get offended
because i put him above like little
wayne but what
i'll be like bro it's my face because
like people that are my favorites
as people or people i just mean like
your favorite is music not as people
i can't put that into five well give me
just throw some names you don't even
know maybe maybe like three give me
three names in no order
no order rihanna
aliyah okay give me some rappers oh you
want rap i want
i want we talking hip hop here oh my bad
okay shout out to riri we need some
music from you
it's been too long okay
i just don't want to be cliche you know
what i'm saying like
i really like okay
like i'll put jay-z up there cause
like i just i mean he's he's daisy
he raps really good of course
i would put drake up there cause drake's
pen
to me i finally met drake
two weeks ago and he had he had the
softest hands ever
i gave him a dab and i was like bro
i just feel like i dapped up a pillow
like what kind of experience
he does hand masks i just yeah he gotta
be doing something i gotta get some hand
masks
he's the only artist i've ever met that
i felt had an actual like
aura around him like i was like oh
that's because he rapped so good yeah
he's kind of stupid bro me and freddie
gibbs met him at uh
some some bar over here and we got we
took shots with him and i was like
yo this guy's glowing you know what i'm
saying maybe it's the skin routine
yeah but super nice guys so drake hove
give me one more name
[Music]
i just don't want like to get like
ridiculed you won't
come on relax he gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
the internet
okay
no i'm really really thinking about this
because like i i'm going down
there's a couple people there throw the
couple names out there okay
i love travis i love future i love
little babies
rowdy rich's music is crazy to me those
are like some of my favorite artists i
listen to them all the time
in the rap world who would you say uh
personally has influenced your style the
most
me you mm-hmm okay
oh and wait time out time timeout i
forgot somebody really high on my list
that i have to throw up there because he
hasn't put on music in a really long
time
but when he does i'm waiting to hear it
kendrick oh yeah kendrick come on man i
forgot kendrick but
don't ever let me forget kendrick again
kendrick is uh
i always tell people he's top five all
time no debate absolutely no debate
because if if if you putting biggie in
your top five and big you only put out
two albums you got to put kendrick in
your [ __ ] because he's put out
classic classic classic good kid mad
city was one of the most
incredibly constructed bodies of work
i've ever heard
in my entire life i don't disagree shout
out to kate the first time i heard
backseat freestyle
i almost jumped out the window like out
the car
in a moving car on the highway well
thank god you didn't thank god i didn't
because i wouldn't be here right now
yeah
or or you'd be here you would just look
[ __ ] up
like what happened to be a man her face
was all [ __ ] up she jumped out of a
vehicle 50 miles an hour
why it was good in our city yeah it was
all kennedy freestyle
um what i mean i know that um festivals
are coming up
finally shows are opening back up thank
god thank god
uh i know you have some big shows that
you're on coming up in this as it was
calling at the summertime what are some
of that
which ones are you looking forward to
the most looking forward to the most
rolling loud lollapalooza yeah both of
those are crazy
the rolling loud lineup is almost unfair
it's like
who who is not on that show it looks so
fun it almost looks
fake it's such a good lineup mm-hmm i'm
happy i'm happy to be on it
shout out to you i'm gonna really [ __ ]
that show up i was gonna say do you do
like when you do a festival show that is
is for a big crowd that maybe
not everyone's there just for you as
opposed to when you do a bs show do you
do you approach them differently
or is it the same vibe no matter what no
i go to [ __ ] up
every show every time i have a show like
i'm going
i'm i'm taking people with me you crowds
her favor
no only because i wear like jewelry and
i'm titties and i don't want to wait to
grab them yeah i feel like it'd be it's
tough for chicks to
to crowd surf i just saw some girl crowd
surf who didn't get groped who was it
i don't know but i was like hey good
good for those guys it depends like it
depends what i'm wearing if i were crowd
surf because if i had heels i wouldn't
cross her
if i had like you know some ice cream
scandalous i'm not a crowd surfing
i don't want a nip slip popping up yeah
i don't want enough slip that's fair
that's fair um who is it that you're
like
i know you got a lot of records in the
chamber right now
can you give us a little uh revelation
or maybe uh
some records you got with some other
artists that you're excited for people
to hear
i got a song coming out with g herbal in
the streets is is asking me for it
sweetie
[Music]
g herbal's a good dude yeah he's fine so
you got the g herbal record coming yeah
it's stupid then i got
um some joints with my girl iggy oh iggy
you know iggy's one of the nicest people
i've ever met
she's so nice i always you know she gets
a lot of criticism
and you know what i how do you feel
about her and her music but when i met
her i was like yo you're like the
sweetest girl like like you know
she i feel like she's genuine a lot of
people you know the the media
hip-hop in general probably paints her
in a unfair light because if you meet
her you'll be like she's such a
sweetheart
thanks she's super nice that's how i
felt so you and iggy have multiple songs
we have a couple maybe a little project
little joint project oh no not that but
we
got one off mine i got one off hers and
they're both fire what about uh any more
music with russ
um no but we are going to we just we
suck we just spoke about that actually
that'd be fire that'd be fine um yeah i
got some other stuff coming out i don't
want to give all the tea away
hey you you said you put rihanna's your
all time how how awesome was it to know
that rihanna
heard your music like that you know she
she was a fan of best honor like that's
got to be a big [ __ ] deal
yeah that's a big deal she's like the
goddess of this she doesn't get no
bigger
no better than rihanna to me i always
have arguments with people
um and i love beyonce i love her right
she's the
greatest entertainer probably of our
generation but i love rihanna's music so
much more
i love both i love both too but that
verses
but like why do people do that like why
do people be like oh i love this person
it's really just my wife i argue with
about this oh my god i hate when people
do that
because it's like i'm like rihanna's
harder than beyonce baby no you're a
[ __ ] cry i'm like baby
you got to just let them both do what
they do you know what i'm saying that's
what people i hate when people compare
not compare me because
i take comparisons like in a good way
now because i'd be like oh
she's beautiful that's a nice compliment
whatever you know i don't take it bad
but
i feel like when it comes to the
artistry like you gotta let people
i like when people let me do what i do
like don't don't put me in that you know
what i like nowadays is
uh i'm sure when you first came out i
mean every female rapper was gonna
compare to nikki
but now there's so many successful
thriving artists
that the comparison [ __ ] has gone away
you don't hear that anymore
i get it you get it who do you like like
what do you people just do it with like
looks online like on
on the internet people always be like oh
you look like [ __ ] the internet
mm-hmm you'll be on there like you like
on like look reading comments and [ __ ]
sometimes
sometimes should bother you when i'm
bored like no
because sometimes you get it getting
them comments some comments is ruthless
i hit block like if i really have a
problem with something i'll block it
yeah i'm a spiritual blocker energy
level me too
you're not going to come into my house
and tell me you don't like my curtains
somebody sliding my comments with some
[ __ ] that block
i used to engage i used to fight with
trumpers and [ __ ] on my comments i'm
like you don't [ __ ] these
i'm just bl this block block game is
strong how many people do you think you
have blocked totally oh at least
a a thousand probably that's fair i
probably deserved it too
probably deserved it say something i
don't like and you get blocked
because it's like why would why would
you say
why would you come into my into my
environment
and disrespect my advice that's like me
saying i don't think you should have
this tv here you should move that tv
over there
i'd be like well she's a female who
probably has better interior designs
she's out of my style i would say you
probably have better taste than me
so i might i might listen to you you
better not let no girl come in here try
to move your tv
no my wife she could move it wherever
she wants just your wife but you know
what i'm saying that's it
happy wife happy life a hundred percent
yeah do you uh you know some guys should
take notes
they should you you said you had a
boyfriend
yeah he takes he's great he's taking
those notes yeah he's taking
okay okay that's good yeah for any guys
watching this happy wife happy life you
should just live by that [ __ ]
or be single one of the two pick your
[ __ ] path but you can't
you can't have your cake and eat it too
you can't
some women though man there's i've
noticed that this generation
some women is lo they're okay with some
[ __ ] going down
as long as it don't penetrate their
their knowledge like you you know you'll
see some lady say look i know my man's
doing this thing as long as i don't find
out about i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah that's not me i mean yeah you're
also latina my wife's a mexican she's a
crazy person
so i think it's like in us we're just
not having it
oh you shouldn't by the way i i don't
agree with that you know
state of mind right you've noticed
that's a thing now like yeah
like chicks don't give a [ __ ] anymore
like yeah i don't care whatever but how
many times never anyway
we're not gonna dive down that rabbit
hole we're not gonna do that
shout out to my wife and shout out to
your boyfriend who understands
the concept of happy wife happy life yes
uh that's a nice watch what kind of
watch is it it's a little ap
it's just a little ap oh shout out to
benny
i worked hard for that watch did you
do you get like a discount on jewelry
because you're bia do they
do they say like hey we'll hook you up
but you gotta tag us no
way you gotta find do that people do
that who's the jewelers that do that
i don't know you could probably find one
in boston um
you gotta ask around you better get that
boston to get you get you one of them
boston jewelers
i'll be like what's t i want a discount
or free
what's a question what's the best boston
movie of all time
oh my god we got the town
we got the we got the departed i love
the town you got the one where damon
wayne's
plays on the jazz and the two celtics
fans kidnapped
there's some great ones what's the other
one with them mystic river mystic valley
river
uncut gems casey affleck's stars in the
other one uh gone baby what is it gone
baby baby
isn't that in boston there's a lot of
good boston movies the town
the town love the town let's give the
flowers to the town right now
yeah the town's an amazing movie shout
out to ben affleck
top five historical boston figure of all
time let's give some flowers to ben
affleck
facts shout out shout out to jlo he's
yeah
hey man anytime i i love to see when a
white boy catches him a
beautiful woman just you know outside of
our ring i'll be like
ben you're back in there you're making
us look good bro i see you man
anyway look bia thank you for pulling up
um
yeah the new songs out you got lots of
music out go support you're gonna have a
crazy rest of the year
for certain for certain so much bullet
cab i love being here and i love my
gifts
and i'm coming back so it is done done
deal and then next time
get your dog situated so your dog could
be in here you know we could have me in
the interview
would it be to be in mia she's chilling
today look at her it's lit